Speaker 1: All right. Let's look at some of
your feedback from the last week. Friday feedback
featuring emails, YouTube comments, Twitter
replies, subreddit posts, and all sorts of
other ways that people communicate with us.
You can always email info at David Pakman
dot com, but your posts and commentary on
any of our platforms might be selected. We'll
start with some criticisms. These are not
exactly the most classy criticisms. John wrote
in and said, Do Alvin Bragg and David Pakman
watch three or 4 hours of porn every day of
their miserable lives? Get woke, go broke.
Let's go, Brandon. Now, many of you would
say, David, there's nothing here to actually
address. You're not. You're not right, though.
Get woke. Go broke. As Farron Cousins so beautifully
explained last week, this idea that, quote,
Getting woke makes you go broke really doesn't
seem to be accurate. And in fact, we looked
at some very interesting polling data down
from Florida, which shows that despite the
concerted effort and attack campaign by Ron
DeSantis and other Republicans against Wokeness,
most Floridians and most Americans actually
agree with the fundamental underlying reality
of Wokeness, which is I'm aware of problems
in society and that it would be great to fix
them and this sort of thing so that it actually
does seem that Wokeness is winning. I addressed
that in a segment a few weeks ago as well.
But as far as the other stuff, let's go Brandon
and Alvin Bragg's habits or whatever, I don't
know, maybe go ask someone who cares about
that stuff. Next, the email is from Mauricio,
who wrote in about progressives and firearms.
This is a very interesting email, says, Hey,
David, I'm a U.S. Air Force veteran with experience
with a variety of firearms. I own a few guns,
mainly for recreational purposes, although
there is a self-defense element. I consider
myself a progressive, although I try to be
rational and like to hear other perspectives
to get to the root of issues. There are a
few things I'm interested in your perspective
on. What is your perception of progressive
gun owners? Is this something you would encourage,
discourage or are neutral about? Is there
any message you have for liberal gun owners?
Well, I have many liberal gun owning friends.
As I've said before on the show, I don't really
talk about my ownership or lack thereof of
firearms. I just I just don't I don't see
any reason to necessarily talk about it. I've
opted not to mention whether I do or don't
own firearms. But one of the things I have
said before is I would like the entire situation
around firearms to be different. It should
be much more expensive. Training and licensing
should be much more extensive. You should
be required to have insurance if you have
firearms. There should be limits on more limits
on what firearms people can buy, and in particular,
people under age 25. I've given all that list,
and if I were a firearm owner myself, I would
be more than willing to subject myself to
all of those requirements as well. I would
prefer there be way fewer guns in circulation
and dramatically so. Given the status quo
today. I don't love the idea of the right
wingers being the only ones with the firearms.
That doesn't sound good either. And it's not
about government tyranny, because I think
that that's quite a silly argument. But it's
if you zoom out and you say there's 400 million
firearms in this country. Do I want 370 million
of them in the hands of right wingers, including
a lot of right wing nuts? No, that doesn't
sound particularly good. So I get that this
is sort of like a race to the bottom type
of thing. Well, so if the liberals get the
guns, then I get it. Believe me, I get it.
Given where things are. I don't want the right
wingers to be the only ones with the guns.
Call me crazy. Next email is from James writing
about 2024 and says, Given both Biden's and
Trump's ages, come the next election, there's
a real possibility that either one or both
could have to pull out due to ill health or
worse, pass away last minute. What chaos do
you feel could follow? Thanks, Jim. From Ireland.
Yeah. Listen. Statistically speaking, it is
more likely that people in their late seventies
or early eighties will die than someone who's
45. Statistically. That is absolutely the
case. Whether this is likely, you know, we
we we looked at actuarial tables looking at
Joe Biden and Donald Trump's ages. And it
is still it is still more likely than not
that they will survive to the next election.
But there is no doubt that if either if either
is or both were the nominees and if either
were to die close to the time of the election
or even imagine between the election and the
inauguration, it would be chaotic. And this
is less about the law and more about I mean,
listen, if Trump's winning by four and November
1st, 2024, he dies and Republicans scramble
and they put in I don't know who. Hard to
imagine a scenario where I don't know who
actually wins. Same thing would apply to Joe
Biden. So I think that that would be the most
likely outcome that if one of the candidates,
if a nominee were to die at a very late stage
of the campaign, it's unlikely that whoever
replaces them is going to win that that, I
think, is the most likely outcome. Vomit wrote
in and said, Sorry to hear that you don't
have a channel anymore about the YouTube channel.
I also heard about this from John, who says,
Is it true you got kicked off YouTube? No.
So several weeks ago now, we did an April
Fool's joke saying the right wing mob won
and I lost my YouTube channel. Now, the truth
is, you can't really lose your YouTube channel
or get kicked off. You could get banned from
YouTube for publishing content repeatedly.
That's in violation of YouTube's terms and
conditions. But it's an important thing to
remember that they can't really take your
YouTube channel from you or shut it down.
And I am really thrilled to be able to say
that actually the channel had its best month
in a really long time in March. April is looking
incredible, you know. Not long ago, I had
the goal of saying, I want to steadily get
a million views a day on YouTube, steadily,
not just like, Oh, here's a good day. We got
a million, but we're averaging way fewer.
We've recently been averaging close to 1.5
million views per day on the YouTube channel,
which is stunning. And I have only you to
thank. So fortunately, the YouTube channel
is alive and well. Let's look at a YouTube
comment. This one's from Thor six for UK U
Q who says about the North Carolina elected
official who switched party from Democratic
to Republican? As a politician, you shouldn't
be allowed to switch parties mid-term. You
should only be allowed to do it when running
for reelection. That way, the voters know
who they are voting for. It's an interesting
idea. Understand that you would, of course,
have to announce that. You could be a Democrat
if you announced that you're running for reelection
a year before the election, you would be announcing
then I'm running as a Republican. So you're
still sort of making it known just as early
and you could still vote however you wanted.
So while it's an interesting idea from Thayer,
I don't know that in practical terms, it really
solves the issue that I think they're getting
at. Feedback about last week's guest hosts.
The good news, as I mentioned on the bonus
show on Monday, is that almost everybody who
wrote in about last week's guest hosts, which
included producer Pat Luke Beazley and Farron
Cousins, almost everybody who wrote in said,
I liked at least one of them. And that's a
really great thing. Michael says Pat and Luke
did the best jobs of handling the show, hands
down. Pat being the better of the two. But
both were more true to your demeanor. I would
much rather see these two guest hosts alternate
alternate days, assuming it's difficult to
prepare daily. So that's Michael. Steven wrote
in and said, providing feedback that I much
prefer Luke as a host. The reason for this
is that I watch your show for political commentary
with a progressive touch. For Ron, Cousins
comes off as a left wing preacher, and it's
very off putting his vibe just doesn't match
the show, you or Pat with two T's. So a lot
going on spelling wise. But a very interesting
bit of feedback. And then other people wrote
in and said, Farrands, the only one that I
watched. Other people wrote in and said, You
know, the problem with Sharon and Luke is
they have their own channel. So then I end
up seeing they cover the stories and then
they cover them for you. And it doesn't make
sense. But the whole idea was something for
everyone, and I would call it an unmitigated
success. But we'll keep trying different formulations
in the future. Lastly, a post from Reflex
point on the subreddit who says I was impressed
with Gavin Newsom. I get the feeling he's
gearing up to be in line for a 2028 run or
even 2024. If something were to happen to
Biden before the election. I think this interview
he had with Brian Tyler Cohen was very good
and worth watching. He has a fighting spirit
that I think Dems need and he's not afraid
to take the fight to the right and put him
on the defensive, even if it's not him. We
need someone that is not afraid to be confrontational
with Republicans. Brian Tyler Cohen's interview
with Gavin Newsom was excellent. I recommend
you check that out. And I tend to agree. And
as I've said before, I don't think Gavin Newsom
is the be all end all of the progressive politician
of the future. I think he has policy areas
where I agree, policy areas where he's sort
of like, okay, but the critical thing about
Newsom is he is willing to be ruthless in
the way that the left should be ruthless when
it comes to these Republicans. That's a very
good thing. Not everybody's willing to do
it. So I think Newsom is a very interesting
guy, although I don't think he is the uber
progressive. But there are many considerations
when we think about who would make a good
nominee, how they would handle attacks from
Republicans is an important part of that.
How what would their demeanor be in debates?
Important part of that. All of those things.
Very, very interesting candidate, potential
candidate. He's not he hasn't announced that
he's running. Send me your thoughts. Info
at David Pakman dot com posted the subreddit
or leave a comment on YouTube or whatever
the case may be. Please remember to ensure
that you are subscribed to the YouTube channel.
Hit that subscribe button. We are pushing
our way slowly to 2 million subscribers and
also remember that much of our content is
available in Spanish at David Pakman dot com
slash Spanish. If you know anyone who would
like or benefit from this content but would
better consume it in Spanish rather than English,
let them know about David Pakman dot com slash
Spanish. We will see you on the bonus show
in your.